The Babylon 5 liveaction reboot is dead
but what happened welcome to Sidetrack
your Sci-Fi TV and movie
channel so I recently told you in a
video that plans for a Babylon 5
liveaction reboot a reimagining of the
original series is now not going to
happen back in 2001 JMS announced that
he was working with this CW to bring us
this new show that they were planning to
film it and they were planning to get on
our screens really quickly but three
years later we still have heard nothing
so what happened why didn't it happen
because we got the road home the
animated movie and it did well surely
that should have helped Babylon 5
liveaction reboot but did it actually
harm it so first of all let's tell us
the story
in 1998 we got the final episodes of the
original five seasons of Babylon 5 we
then got a couple of very cool TV movies
and a spin-off series that failed very
quickly but Babylon 5 has continued to
be among sci-fi fans in particular one
of the great shows it was actually
conceived as Five Seasons from the
beginning it was a proper Space Opera it
was dramatic
it told a story in a way we've not
really seen before and to be honest I
did a video not long ago saying how
Babylon 5 inspired sci-fi for two
decades following it so when news that
it was going to get a reboot came along
a lot of fans were very excited a lot of
fans were not but we'll come back to
that in a minute because let's talk
about sort of the business side of this
and why this show didn't end up on the
CW so I should should say that the CW is
a show that actually did originally show
Babylon 5 when it was called whatever it
was called back then so CW was
technically the home of Babylon 5 and
actually Mark pedowitz which was the guy
that was in charge of the CW at the time
was a big fan Jes has actually talked
about how Mark PTZ um back when um the
original babyon 5 was being created
always wanted to know what was going to
happen next and as soon as the edit was
done they'd have to send him a tape sort
of thing so he could see early before
everyone else it's fair to say he was a
Babylon 5 fan and it was him that wanted
to bring back babon 5 for a new audience
but in January 2022 it was announced
that the CW was up for sale and actually
a company called nextstar was going to
be taken over they ended up buying
75% of the CW with Paramount and Warner
Brothers owning a share of the other 25%
now Paramount and Warner Brothers will
continue to make content for the
CW but under new ownership they very
quickly began to change direction if you
are enjoying the video don't forget to
like subscribe with the Bell
notification all those things but also
go over to
patreon.com sidre that is where most of
our videos do Premiere first and you get
to see them without all the adverts for
a small fee that really helps out the
channel new owners said that the network
needed to be um run in a far more
responsible way that a lot of the TV
shows on the network cost twice as much
as a lot of TV shows on other networks
and if you're honest you can see that a
lot of the TV shows they were creating
for DC the arrowe series were expensive
to produce for a TV show but actually if
you watch Superman and Lois my God
that's a good show and really expensive
to produce so I can understand where
next star we coming from and only a
couple of months after the original
announcement in May
2022 several shows were cancelled a lot
of the DC Universe stuff was cancelled
and actually only recently um the
Superman series was also cancelled
ending the arrow verse forever and then
the hammer blow that really probably
ended Babylon 5 ever appearing on the CW
again happened in October of 2022 next
star bought the 75% not for money by the
way they just agreed to take on $100
million of the debt something Paramount
and actual Warner Brothers were very
happy about um but they take over and
then Mark pedowitz resigned following
that the CW started to announce that it
wanted to do shows for maybe a slightly
older generation they wanted to do sort
of procedural cop shows and more reality
TV stuff that was cheaper to make but
had really good numbers and they signed
a big deal to show golf and other spor
and events the CW Now is going in a
completely different direction and
babble on five just doesn't really fit
that new Direction but Warner Brothers
didn't give up and I was able to
exclusively tell you on Sidra that they
were exploring other options that
apparently Apple were interested but
apparently Apple are interested in
everything and then Amazon were
interested apparently Amazon saw babyon
5 as a possible show for the freee
network they are actively looking for
new shows for freee and they just felt
that a maybe lower budget Babylon 5
series would have fit perfectly and to
be honest I can see it it was around
this time the Babylon 5 the road home
came out now initially that seemed to
actually strengthen the sales pitch
because the road home DVD Blu-ray Etc
sales did really well people seem to
like it but the problem was it
underlined the fundamental issue with a
reboot of the original Babylon 5 series
a lot of fans didn't want it they look
at the road home with the original
characters in and voiced by a lot of the
original actors sadly a lot of them also
passed away and they remembered the
Babylon 5 series and they started saying
can't we have a continued ation I don't
want a hard reboot of a show I loved we
don't need a hard reboot of the show we
loved and that message was heard by
Executives at Amazon and apple Etc they
came back and just said look we love
Babylon 5 we'd love to have something to
do with it but it's not going to work as
a hard reboot so does that mean we could
get something else within the Babylon 5
Universe well yeah yes and no no in that
it's very unlikely we're going to get
anything else from The Babylon 5
Universe because JMS said it himself
people don't want to buy it they wanted
to buy Babylon 5 because the name people
know they don't really think it's a sort
of franchisable
show but yes because the road home did
do well and we could get to see more
animated movies and maybe even an
animated series spinning off from that
Warner Brothers have a bit of a business
model for this they've been doing it
with DC movies for years and they always
do really well they're animated and
produced relatively cheaply if I'm
honest but because they do all of the
movies and series Etc using the same
technology it's efficient they can
produce them very quickly they can
produce them very secretly we saw that
with Road home nobody knew it was coming
out until about a couple of months
before we had it in our hands and they
can use quite a lot of them Babylon 5
the road home it did do very well and it
opened the door to potential reboots
maybe in that they can do the different
universes I think that's what JS was
thinking about when he wrote it if I'm
honest for the liveaction
series but people will not accept a
liveaction rebooted babon 5 it would
have a lot of negativity thrown at it
before it was ever released and to be
hon honest it's almost destined to fail
but animated movies based around the
original being voiced by as many of the
original actors as possible and maybe
even using AI to replicate some of the
voices of others if you know that's
necessary would be interesting for fans
we would love to dip our toes back into
the universe of Babylon 5 maybe see some
prequels or see some stuff from some of
the time gaps we had within the series
I'd love to personally see more of the
mbari war Etc now that would excite fans
and that seems to be what Warner
Brothers are working towards now in
partnership with Amazon who would sell
these like they sold the road
home I actually think that is going to
be the future of Babylon 5 and the
liveaction reboot was probably not the
greatest idea in the first place but
guys what do you think get the comments
is Babylon 5 reboot a brilliant idea or
a terrible idea I'd love for you to tell
me and is it going to be a shame that
we're not going to see what jmss would
have done with this at the end of the
day now he's had a few more Decades of
development and having this idea bounced
around in his head isn't it going to be
a bit of a shame that we're not going to
see what he'd have come up with I think
so but guys get into the comments and
tell me exactly what you think if you
are new to the Channel please like
subscribe hit all those Bell buttons and
things so you never miss any of our new
videos but also go to patreon.com sidk
if you are desperate to see the videos
first because almost all of them Premier
on there up to a day before they do on
YouTube so go check that out also check
out our dedicated website
c.co we do articles based on a lot of
our videos um so go and check that out
too as always please stay safe and I'll
see you next
[Music]
time